the government appears to have conceded
for the first time that the Prime
Minister cannot Parag Parliament in
order to force through a No Deal brexit
in response to a legal letter from the
businesswoman an anti brexit campaigner
Gina Miller the government's lawyers say
Parliament won't be prevented from
sitting in the period leading up to the
UK's exit on October the 31st and his
Miller who took the government to court
and won the right for Parliament to
trigger article 50 reassembled her legal
team last month with instructions to
stop Boris Johnson shutting down
Parliament and forcing through a No Deal
brexit against MPs wishes well Gina
Miller is here
good morning nice to see you look I've
read through this response if there's a
lot of legalese in there break it down
for us what exactly are they saying to
you well what they've said is
unequivocally they accept that to close
down Parliament to bypass them in terms
of brexit so stopping a no deal breaks
it in particular is illegal so without
having to go to court they've conceded
we've basically called their bluff so
they're saying in effect that there are
rules in place where they have to meet
for a certain amount of time before
October 31st
yes the MPs passed this North Nile and
the executive act and under Section
three of that the the MPs will have
three occasions of several days at a
time between the fourth of September and
the 31st of October and the government
as I said has given me huge amount of
reassurances and has gone through great
lengths to say yes we absolutely agree
that the MPs will have that opportunity
so it's a lot of bluster what they're
saying that MPs will be denied that
opportunity so perogy
of the Commons will not happen but the
Prime Minister is heading to Germany in
France this week where he's going to say
amongst other things no deal cannot be
stopped if that is the only option it is
that actually true then well whilst
they've given this reassurance of no
corrugation of parliament one of the
central tenants of my legal letter to
the prime minister was to say that if
you deny primary MPs the ability to pass
legislation to stop no deal that would
be contrary to Parliament's sovereignty
so we will be going back again to seek
that reassurance amongst others that
they will allow Parliament to pass
legislation to stop No Deal but it still
leaves a very big question mark doesn't
it and there are lots of people coming
forward we talk to them all the time
saying you know this this cannot happen
Parliament will not allow it to happen
but what you're effectively saying is
ultimately it could happen and there's
nothing anyone could actually do to stop
it well at the moment their parliament
has to find a way instruments and ways
of ensuring that they can pass that
legislation scrutinizing it which is
what the government letter has confirmed
that Parliament will be able to
scrutinize and examine all options when
it comes to exiting is not the same as
giving them the ability to pass
legislation and because we already have
in legislation that the 31st of October
is our exit day they need to pass other
legislation to prevent no deal or to
change that date ask for an extension so
forgetting about you know who's going to
be king of the castle in a union
government or etc I would say this
letter shows that MPs really have to
concentrate and ensuring that they have
that opportunity and we will go back to
make sure that the MPs are given that
opportunity via further legal assurances
but probation is off the table right so
in all of this though we are you know
because you've studied this more than
most of us the parliamentary arithmetic
and the fact and the timescale involved
in the fact that they're all on holiday
at the minute in effect means that is
that change of legislation to primary
legislation is very unlikely to happen I
don't believe that at all because
actually you and you have to question
why the conference season for example
the Parliament is rising for those three
weeks we still have an opportunity where
Parliament could be brought back and has
to sit and it doesn't take long actually
if you could do it within 24 hours so
the fact is MPs need to find the tool to
do that and if they choose to do so to
be prevented by the Prime Minister from
passing legislation we feel it would be
illegal not least based on the judgement
in my first case so what more action is
it possible for you to take if you
wanted to pursue it further oh we will
be pursuing it further we will go back
to a with another our reply to the
government's reply
making further reassurances but in
particular the assurance that MPs will
have the opportunity to bring
legislation if they wish to do so the
last time you're on this program the
Home Secretary appeared not long
afterwards and said look it's not
acceptable to use the calls to tie the
hands of MPs I mean aren't you in effect
looking for legal loopholes to stop
these people who have been elected into
office doing their job but that's C
exactly that is the point
it is ensuring elected MPs have the
opportunity to do their job and
protecting parliamentary sovereignty
which is what my first case is about and
this is exactly the same in that a prime
minister is not above the law and
actually this is what they've agreed in
the letter that Boris Johnson is not
above the law which is great to hear and
that they can't bypass Parliament and we
just need to make sure that
parliamentarians have the opportunity to
be sovereign and yet in terms of being
sovereign Parliament was sovereign
wasn't when it agreed the extension and
the exit date of the 31st some would
argue that they've made that decision
the democratic process within parliament
has happened that decisions been made
now it needs to be stuck - well
Parliament doesn't just happen on one
day it's an ongoing process and more
than ever you see today the yellowhammer
document you know when you now see what
we're facing when it comes to No Deal
then parliamentarians are expressing
their view and they rightly they that's
why we elect them to protect us and
that's what they're going to they're
going to try and do protect us from this
disastrous No Deal well I mean you've
been accused and and to be fair lots of
people who who want to either remain or
stop or no deal have been accused of of
scaremongering project fear it's been I
don't think you can say that now now
you've got the government's own paper
well nobody's gonna say in relation to
yellowhammer this document this leaked
cabinet document that says you know
there may be that a prepare for
shortages of food fuel and medicines the
government says well that's looking at a
worst-case scenario that's planning for
the worst they don't expect any of that
to happen that's not what the report
says and actually it's even now has
changed from the original report and now
it says that there is likely to be a
hard border in Ireland so it also says
things that there are no bilateral
agreements with any of our Member States
the fact that our chemicals for our
waters actually can't be stockpiled the
three courts of our matter
come from the EU these are not scare
mongering stories this is the
government's own assessment and if you
then add that to the Bank of England's
assessment the office of budget
responsibilities assessments you know
how many more how much more torrent of
assessments do you need to realize that
this is putting people's lives in danger
one thing the Prime Minister has made it
very clear about is the idea that he
wants a new deal I mean in effect he's
going to be you and say give us a free
trade deal or we're gonna leave anyway
now the more you do to rule out the
possibility through legal means and the
more that MPs doing the House of Commons
to rule out the possibility of a No Deal
brexit you just undermine his position
don't you in trying to actually get the
sort of deal which he thinks would be
good for this country no because there
are two different things
one is leaving with in a way that is if
we do leave that it's not no deal and
then the second part which is the
difficult bit we haven't even started is
negotiating the future relationship and
that so the two things mixing them up is
actually not how the process works so
they are two completely separate thing
one is leaving and the other is actually
then negotiating over if we were to get
a deal over the next two years or so or
however long it takes to get that future
relationship but he has said he wants a
deal and by taking no deal off the table
that does weak in his hand doesn't it
they can just turn around and say you've
got a deal and we're not going to change
it which is although said so far well
yes and I don't know who exactly is
negotiating with because there's nobody
sitting in European in the commission
till November so the idea that there's a
lot of bluster and propaganda going on
here and from our point of view we've
just taken one off the table they've
agreed with us propogation it's not a
tool that they can use now we have to
look at all the other issues and see if
the Prime Minister is actually acting
within the law okay Gina may look very
good to talk to you this morning thank
you very much indeed